I am the sword in the darkness I am The
Watcher on the walls I am the shield
that guards the realms of men
I pledged my life and honor to the
Nights Watch for this night and all the
nights to come
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 discussion video this video is gonna
be a little bit different than what I
usually do I want to talk about the
crypts of Winterfell because this has
always been one aspect of the story that
fascinates me but I am not necessarily
going to be predicting anything myself
because I have already done that in a
previous video about this subject what I
want to do is discuss some other very
interesting things about the crypts and
I want to see what all of you have to
say about these things personally I have
always felt that the crypts of
Winterfell
would come into play in terms of the
endgame but with only six episodes left
in the television show I'm not exactly
sure what they can do at this point I
can obviously make a few guesses but I
would rather discuss several of the
potential scenarios the show could go
with then I want to see what all of you
think is most likely to happen there are
some really cool theories out there
about the crypts of Winterfell but I
think most of them are pertaining to the
books but even though there is only six
episodes left I still feel like the
crypts can be useful when telling the
ending of this story in the TV series at
the very least there could be something
really cool down in those crypts but if
they're gonna take us back down there
one last time what purpose can it serve
now when season 8 begins we are finally
gonna have all of the Starks back in
Winterfell for the very first time since
season 1 but not only will all of the
remaining Starks be there but so will
Daenerys and her dragons and if there is
one thing we all know about the dragons
is they seem to make magic a hell of a
lot stronger so there is no telling what
kind of crazy [ __ ] could awaken down
there on those crypts if anything at all
Winterfell would Sailfish shrouded a
mystery but the crypts that lie beneath
the castle are even more mysterious and
all of the Starks have this strange
connection
them and george RR martin has left all
these breadcrumbs throughout the books
that let us know this is a very special
place for the Starks and it's not just
because this is where they keep their
loved ones after they have passed there
is a much bigger secret down there just
waiting to be revealed
which i believe george will do in one of
the last books but i am really curious
if whether or not we will get a taste of
this in the final season it would be the
perfect time to do this in my opinion
considering everyone will be there
together i am pretty confident we will
get at least one more scene down there
but maybe even more when john arrives in
Winterfell he's gonna learn about his
true parents from bran and knowing John
he's gonna want to return to the crypts
to see his mother Leona and he will
probably go down there and see Ned again
- and just think about how he had kept
us a secret this entire time to protect
him but if you have not read the books
then you might not know this but John
has always had this very strong
connection with the crypts John used to
have dreams about them all the time and
John had dreamt that he was wandering
the empty Castle searching for his
father while descending into the crypts
only this time the dream had gone
further than before in the dark he'd
heard the scrape of stone on stone and
when he turned he saw that the vaults
were opening one after another as the
dead Kings came stumbling from their
cold black graves now that is a very
creepy dream to have and it must have
some meaning to it
John had another dream that he was down
there but this time he was limping past
the stone King's on their Thrones their
gray granite eyes turned to follow him
as he passed and their gray fingers
tightened on the hilts of the rusted
swords upon their laps John could hear
the dead Kings telling him that he is
not a stark and they would tell him
there is no place for him in the crypts
he should go away but something is
calling to John down there there are
many levels within the crypts and the
one that interests me the most is the
lowest level of them all there is a
section of the crypts that is in
complete darkness and it's partially
collapsed I have always felt like
something might be in there and it could
be the thing that has been calling to
John all of these years personally I
always associated these dreams with
John's lineage
or parents I should say when John would
have dreams of being down there in the
dead kings of winter telling him he
doesn't belong there and that he's not a
stark this may have been telling us the
truth about John the dead kings of
winter were right what we found out
these last two seasons of the show
John is not a stark but he's a
legitimate Targaryen and the crypts of
Winterfell are meant for Starks only but
not all Starks technically speaking
Lyanna stark should not have been down
there but Ned did in anyway and there
are several theories revolving around
Leon a statue that is down there and it
could come into play during the final
season some people say there might be
some kind of artifact or proof about Jon
Snow's lineage inside of Leona statue
some say Ned may have put Rhea gars harp
inside of her statue while others say
Sir Arthur Dayne sword Don might be
inside there as well which could end up
being Lightbringer considering it is
already a very special sword that is
said to have been made out of a fallen
star which both form house Dayne sigil
Ned said he returned to sword to star
fall but Sir Arthur Dayne sister ashara
dayne allegedly committed suicide
shortly after this and heard that body
in the sword hasn't been seen since so
who knows there is no telling what Ned
may have taken from the Tower of joy and
put inside of Leon a statue in the
crypts I did believe there was something
inside of her statue but now I have to
ask myself are they really gonna do this
at this point does Jon need to find
something down there to believe the
truth about his parents because I don't
see why Jon wouldn't believe Bryan when
he tells him what he saw
during his flashback plus I'm sure Sam
will confirm this by showing Jon the
journal that was kept about Ray Gore's
annulment and his new marriage but let
me ask all of you this do you believe
there are something inside of leiana's
statue waiting for Jon and if so what do
you think it is if there isn't anything
inside of her statue then do you believe
there is something in the crypts at all
waiting for Jon to find it
perhaps in the lowest level of the
crypts that are partially collapsed I do
think there is a very strong possibility
something is down there some people also
believe there might be a dragon or
dragon eggs under Winterfell one of the
main reasons people believe this theory
is because there was once a dragon in
Winterfell many years
go when the pact of Ice and Fire was
established this was an alliance made
between houses Stark and Targaryen
during the dance of dragons at the time
Prince Jack Ari's of Dragonstone flew on
his dragon vert max to Winterfell to
meet with Creegan stark and while he was
there many people believed vormax may
have laid eggs within the crypts of
Winterfell even some of the small folk
of the north have been known to say that
the hot poles are heated by a dragon
living under the castle personally I
kind of find it hard to believe a dragon
is living under there because it would
have to come out and eat at some time
and people would notice a dragon flying
around wonderful eventually but dragon
eggs being down there is a little bit
more plausible but still a bit of a
stretch but I have always found it very
interesting that Winterfell was built
over natural hot springs the water is
piped through the walls and chambers to
heat them which makes Winterfell a hell
of a lot more bearable in the wintertime
it's genius for many reasons but could
there be a deeper meaning to this
perhaps a bigger purpose bran the
Builder is the one who built Winterfell
anni also built the wall I think there
might be a specific reason why he chose
this exact location to build crypts deep
into the ground there is another theory
that I want to talk about because I find
this one very intriguing in this theory
kind of influenced my theory about why I
think the Great War will end and
Winterfell ever since I started to talk
about the night king being defeated in
Winterfell many of you have asked me
about the dead kings of winter having
any kind of role in this well there is a
theory that states the crypts of
Winterfell are actually a prison that
bran the Builder had built to contain
the great other or more specifically the
night king this is more of a book theory
because in the books george RR martin
has more or less stated that the night's
king we know today isn't the same
night's king that was the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch which
means there has been more than one
night's king over the centuries most of
you already know why I believe the
Starks castle was called Winterfell I
think this is where the king of winter
or the god of winter literally fell from
power the name of the castle was kind of
a reminder that this is where the night
king had been defeated before this is
where the king of winter for many
generations ago had fell but over time
the me
the name winter fowl had been forgotten
another interesting way to look at this
is why are the older Starks in the
crypts called the kings of winter could
it be because they are the ones that
were needed to defeat the night king the
person who brings the storm and the long
night unless some of those kings of
winter and the crypts are all former
Knights Kings that were defeated and
locked up down there this is why the
Starks were always warning people that
winter was coming these words lost their
true meaning over time just like the
name of their castle Winterfell lost the
meaning of its name over time but it all
relates to the night King and like I
have said before this is why a stark
must always remain in Winterfell they
are the only ones who hold the true
power over the others what is very
interesting though is when Winterfell
was actually built bran the Builder
constructed the castle when it scripts
right after the others were defeated
legend says that Brandon the Builder
razed Winterfell after the generation
long winter known as the long night that
could be a clue as to why Brennan the
Builder made the crypts of Winterfell
right after the long night had ended
this cavernous vault which is longer
than Winterfell itself has several
levels to it with vaults even deeper and
darker where the older kings were buried
and don't forget about the section that
is partially collapsed where no one has
been that could be the location of the
night's king that was defeated during
the long night that could be where the
original king of winter resides and this
may be why Brandon the Builder decided
to build this over the natural Hot
Springs that does sound like a good
place to keep the gods of winter in
prison for eternity but you know what's
even crazier
even though Winterfell was built over
natural Hot Springs the crypts are
always still very cold when Ned takes
Robert down here to see Lyanna the book
references how robert was shivering in
the subterranean chill because it was
always cold down there if you have
something basically made of ice locked
up down there then it could explain why
it's always so cold down there but there
was also something Ned Stark used to
dream about that could be another clue
as to what's really going on while Ned
was in King's Landing he dreams of the
crypts of Winterfell and he envisions
the kings of winter watching him with
eyes of ice
those last three words always jumped out
at me when that's all the kings of
winter in his dreams they had eyes of
ice there was only one other thing that
comes to my mind when I think of eyes of
ice and that's the great other I'm sure
this theory probably sounds very wacky
to some of you but it really makes a lot
of sense to me
they might not go in this direction in
the show but for the books it seems very
plausible there are way too many
connections between the Starks and
Winterfell and brain in the Builder and
the night king or Knights King for me to
dismiss this theory I think it would be
incredible if this was one of the big
reveals but it's just my opinion and you
can certainly disagree with me if you
want to regardless of how it ends I do
believe there is one more big secret
that lies within those crypts and I am
leaning towards us getting another big
reveal in the final episodes but let me
know what you think about any of this
down below in the comment section I have
to thank you all for watching this video
especially if you made it this far and I
hope you did otherwise most of what I
said will not make much sense but in my
opinion I believe the crypts have more
to do with the others in the night King
than any other Theory out there
considering how much evidence has been
put forth in the books Winterfell was
built immediately after the long night
ended and it was built by the same
person who built the wall I think this
is where the night King had fallen
during the war and he may have been
imprisoned in the crypts to ensure he
didn't get free again it would explain
why this location was chosen right over
the natural Hot Springs it would kind of
counteract the magic the night king has
over the ice and if he was in the crypts
it would also explain why they are
always so cold even with the hot water
rushing through the walls of the castle
maybe the Starks have other magic
besides warding that helps keep any of
the others imprisoned down there and
that's why a stark must always remain
there or it's just because a star can
stop the night king from taking over
Winterfell and freeing whatever is down
there and of course the Starks always
have dreams about the crypts and I think
Ned's dream may be very telling when he
says he saw the dead King staring back
at him with eyes of ice it makes a lot
of sense to me but maybe I am just crazy
let me know what you think though does
Winterfell
or it's crypts have any significance to
you and do you think they will serve any
purpose in the end put all your thoughts
questions and opinions down below thank
you for watching and thank you to all of
my patreon supporters
I hope you all have a great day I'll see
you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you